let's stay there uh boris johnson has
now written to his former health
secretary sergey javid let's have a read
of what uh boris johnson has had to say
uh dear sajid thank you for your letter
this evening tendering your resignation
i was very sorry to receive it
you have served this government and the
people of the united kingdom with
distinction most recently you have led
the department of health and social care
as we learned to live with kovid forging
ahead with plans to beat the coveted
backlogs recruit 50 000 nurses build 40
new hospitals and reform social care
these are the issues that matter to the
people of this country and the
government will continue to deliver on
them you have held significant positions
in government for the past decade and
have served myself and former prime
ministers admirably you have used your
personal experience to bring about
change in government from fixing the
injustices of windrush to setting out
recently a plan to address suicide you
will be greatly missed and i look
forward to your contribution from the
back benches uh yours ever boris it says
there
he of course has resigned twice from
boris johnson's government we remember
the first time and this is the second
absolutely and i think the uh that's
again quite a nice letter there from the
prime minister to sanji javi but no
doubt he will be disappointed um at this
resignation because saji javid is seen
by some as a potential future leader he
of course ran in the leadership contest
against
boris johnson so i think
again a nice
polite send-off there but i think he
will be very disappointed to lose him